[Music]
new struggle to look for that perfect
frame that fits your face shape well
what's this video through as image
consultant to WA share with us these
useful tips to keep it simple our faces
fall into two categories
rounded or angular so to determine which
category you fall into observe your face
from the nose and below especially the
jawline do you have a gradual straight
line and rounded chin like me which both
under the rounded category or do you
have an angular line just like you are
or maybe a pointed chin which falls
under the angular category when choosing
a frame shape we want to find a frame
that is in contrast with the face shape
this brings balance and proportion to
one's face so if you fall under the
roundel category avoid round of frames
[Music]
choose angular frames instead in
contrast if you fall under the angular
category of both angular frames and go
for rounded frame next determine if you
have a cold or warm skin undertone to
create balance choose print colors that
are in accordance with your skin
undertone choosing your fin color with
the same skin undertone when they can
look more vibrant if you happen to have
a low nose bridge just like me ask for
an Asian sheet frame which comes with a
narrow bridge adjustable nose pass and
has a decreased curvature if you have
higher cheekbones avoid bigger frames
which will touch against your cheekbones
to smaller frames instead for those of
you who have visible dark circles under
the eyes Kluwer recommends a speaker and
socket own full rim frame big enough to
cover the dark circle area to create a
lifting effect on your face be
adventurous and try the cat eye frame
and if you want to instantly look
younger well just colorful and brighter
frames so remember to also too
to frame their fits your style and
personality both and loud the screams
fashionable or classic and functional
that channels your elegance we hope this
video has been helpful to give this
video a thumb up share it and subscribe
to my youtube channel due policy far for
more styling tips don't forget to also
turn on to the notification button so
that you will get notified every time I
upload a new video all the best